we're excited to be able to show a new
version of Minecraft built specifically
for microsoft hololens it's creepy I
don't know where my face but okay it's a
future payment Eric Tommy Jason hi
reckless Tortuga okay alright
so this you've never heard of no another
Nerd Herd I saw the commercial for it
and I thought that was a concept yeah I
didn't know there was a real thing this
is going to change gaming forever
Microsoft demoed their new peripheral
for the Xbox called Halloween did it so
we're gonna show this to Tommy for the
first time he's not seeing this demo
watch my reaction doing it live as I
watched the video what you're seeing
right now is like ooh you can see on the
screen and so you put a screen on like
you're playing on a screen on a wall but
the screens not really there so that's
not that cool we're like okay why don't
just buy a TV watch this Tommy it's
gonna blow your mind out of here that's
crazy that's crazy that's crazy
that's everything teach your child that
you hope you can actually do one but oh
my god that's me but tell me it doesn't
matter to you that it's all in this game
there's other stuff there's gonna be
other I'm sure the technology is cool
I'll give you that but this do you ever
play Minecraft no that's the one I love
minecraft do they have an idea of what
the price boys gonna be on that I would
assume probably a grand I'll grant they
want to make it available for consumers
I know but a grand that's way too
expensive isn't it what is this any more
of his same thing no it's VR it's like
that means that you just it was a
reality this is augmented reality Sony's
doing virtual reality in essence you're
like life's not fun guys pornographic
films
wait are you guys kidding here's a
question is it cheating an 8-bit
minecraft character
here's the thing if your wife walks in
on you yeah you're gonna be jerking off
and staring into the air so exactly what
are you doing nothing you could be like
I'm jerking off well why did you have
those huge ass goggles over your head
it's protection no you could say you're
having like an eye exam maybe these are
my okay guys here's what I don't like
about it I don't like Minecraft I don't
like that to experience this and to get
pumped for it I have to go through this
Minecraft version of it I'll take the
later version of it
next I don't care I'm an adult alright I
have a hard enough time with life how do
you spell what is an adult that when
you're over 18 Eric they showed a couple
months ago a professor literally talking
to his class and then literally changed
the whole ground in kumar's and that is
cool that's why I said next
it's like a Minecraft version there's
about minecraft so it is about Minecraft
okay fine
thank you you're not gonna have to play
Minecraft I won't mean you tonne in my
house so you can turn my house into Mars
we go for a stroll on Mars together
wonderful thank you guys for watching so
much with wreckless tortuga subscribe to
us we got a ton of stuff coming for you
to get reckless Tortuga new media
rockstars also comment below how stupid
Erica is being about my guy you love
Mike
I get it minecraft popular so do you
want to attack me go for it it's not
even about minecraft though it's about
for changing game it's about the
hololens yeah it's about the future our
future together
I hope what's out a Jason